for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so metabolism of amino acids occurs
at least for the most part in the liver
okay so how does the protein that we eat
become the amino acids metabolized in
our liver that's what this video is
basically about now it just has a
forewarning there are tons of perhaps
unnecessary details ahead you may need
to know them for whatever you're
studying you may not I don't know but
there's just brace yourself okay so the
first question here is in which organ
does protein digestion begin and that is
the stomach so we're going to take in
food through our oral cavities and go
down to our Safa GISS right and into our
stomach and that's where the action gets
started and then we have some digestion
occurring in the small intestine okay so
this is just an overview of the actual
organs involved in the digestive system
but not as important as what we're
getting into here alright so I hope
you've braced yourself for the details
okay so we're gonna go through this step
by step first things first step a we
start off with this dietary protein here
and it's coming down from the esophagus
into the stomach so here protein arrives
to the stomach and stimulates G cells of
the gastric mucosa to secrete gastrin
which is a peptide hormone okay so
that's shown basically right here just
the arrival of the protein here
stimulates the cells of the stomach the
G cells specifically do produce and
secrete gastrin the second thing Part B
here part b
gastrin does two things it is going to
stimulate parietal cells parietal cells
to secrete pepsinogen pepsinogen and
it's also going to stimulate chief cells
chief cells to secrete HCL or
hydrochloric acid so that's what's
happening right here in Part B we're
stimulating the cells of the stomach to
produce these two things right the
parietal cells produced pepsinogen right
here and the chief cells produce the HCL
the hydrochloric acid okay
so part c up next
so let's actually check these off as we
go through them so we've done a done B
so again it doesn't be next up is C so C
HCl of course is a strong acid and it'll
bring the pH of the the it'll bring the
pH down to really low about one or two
and what that'll do is that'll do three
things it'll kill any bacteria or
foreign particles okay
it'll also denature the dietary protein
so the dietary protein that came in here
this little gray blob that is going to
be denatured right here in Part C right
so here we have the H+ the acid
stimulating the denaturing of of this
protein into a polypeptide shown here
okay and the third thing that that HCl
does where that acid does is it
stimulates pepsinogen to auto cleave
itself to basically cleave itself into
pepsin
okay so pepsinogen is an inactive
precursor to the protein pepsin which is
a protease okay speaking of which that
ends up ends Part C now we're on Part D
pepsin what it's going to do is it's
going to once actually check off this
see over here on the actual diagram as
well so that part there is done so then
Part D the polypeptide the denatured
polypeptide right here
that is going to be cut up into many
smaller peptides by pepsin the active
form of pepsinogen okay pepsin will take
that denature polypeptide and cut it up
into little pieces that are going to be
small peptides okay so that's part D
there okay cool so then we've got Part
II okay so now the peptides are going to
move into the duodenum duodenum of the
small intestine and stimulate the
duodenum to secrete secretin into the
blood secreting yeah okay
and also it's going to stimulate the
duodenum to secrete cholecystokinin or
CCK into the blood okay so that's right
here the part you just these small
peptides moving out into the small
intestine from the stomach they're going
to stimulate the small intestine to
secrete those two hormones into the
blood so that's part ii okay so now we
get into F let's check off each over
here don't eat so F there's two parts to
F F one is basically going to be what
secretin does secretin will stimulate
the release of bicarbonate hco3 minus
from the exocrine pancreas exocrine
pancreas and what that's going to do
that buffer will bring the pH back to
around seven or eight because it was you
know that gastric juice that went from
over here in the stomach into the small
intestine is highly acidic so bringing
that pH back to physiological pH is
important okay so that's F 1 and we got
that bicarbonate right here okay so f 1
don't want that part
bringing the pH back to
seven or eight and then f2 is what's
going on at the c ck the C CK there
cholecystokinin it stimulates the
exocrine pancreas to release
Saima genes which are inactive
precursors of enzymes so f2 over here
we've got the pancreas dump being the
zymogens over here into the small
intestine okay so which zymogens are
they specifically one of them is
trypsinogen so it ends in O Jin meaning
that it's a zymogen we've got kymo
trypsinogen again it's an urchin we also
got pro elastase okay so this one isn't
an OG but it begins with pro generally
if it begins with pro it's a pro enzyme
the difference between damaged ins and
pro enzymes I mean they're pretty much
the same thing they're in active
precursors to active enzymes and the
last one here our last two are pro
carboxy peptidase is a and B okay so
they're inactive precursors of the car
back Cobb Fe that yeah excuse me
carboxypeptidase a and carboxy peptidase
be okay alright and then part G part G
is zymogens are then the zymogens are
then cleaved into active proteases so
that's what's going on here okay so
these damaged ins are all and had two
precursors of enzymes that are actually
going to act as protease is to cut up
these peptides into even smaller
peptides okay so the trypsinogen is
cleaved by entero peptidase to become
trips in the and then that trypsin will
go through and cleave all of these all
these other damaged ends into their
active form so chymotrypsinogen weakly
by trypsin to become kind with trypsin
and then pro elastase we created by
trypsin to be become elastase and pro
car back to the peptidase is a and B
will be turned into carboxy peptidase
--is and B okay so that's part G they're
getting all those
Ziya missions to be active and then part
H of course is those proteases are going
to cleave the peptides into even smaller
peptides so that's what's happening here
we take these little pieces and cut them
up into even smaller pieces here so now
we got really small peptides the next
step is having the carboxy peptidase is
removing the carboxy terminal amino
acids and amino peptidase is removing
the amino terminal amino acids okay so
these small peptides basically we're
gonna remove amino acids off the ends
and so we have just a collection of
amino acids okay so at this point we've
taken taking what we started off with as
a diet you know a large dietary protein
that was turned into a pie peptide and
now we've got amino acids for me after
cleaving it a bunch of times so then
what happens is that was step I I is
done here and then part J amino acids
are absorbed from the intestinal lumen
into the intestinal epithelium so this
portion in here the actual contents of
the tube that is the small intestine
this portion inside is called the lumen
and the intestinal epithelium is the
actual cell layers that make it up so
the epithelium is this part here helium
okay so we're gonna take those amino
acids are gonna go from that space that
is the lumen they're gonna go into the
actual cells of the small intestine and
so we get these amino acids for kind of
if we kind of zoom in on that portion
there we've got the amino acids in the
lumen out here is lumen they're gonna
come into the epithelium like the cells
in here this is the actual cells of the
small intestine so now we got the amino
acids right in there that's part J and
then parts K and L those amino acids are
gonna be taken up from those cells into
the blood so that's what's happening
here all right and then from the blood
they're going to
you be taken they're gonna be taking in
the blood to the liver to the liver so
that's parts K&L right there parts j k
and l and then once they the amino acids
get to the liver they can of course be
metabolized okay I have a question over
here about this situation with these Pro
enzymes and their active forms why is it
that these proteases are made stored and
released as inactive precursors the
answer is that so they do not destroy
the pancreas because if we have the
active proteases in the pancreas that
was just tear apart all the proteins in
the pancreas which of course can be
really bad in fact that can lead to
pancreatitis which apparently I've never
had it before but pancreatitis which is
apparently super painful and actually
potentially lethal so I shouldn't fret
too much though because the pancreas has
a protein called pancreatic trypsin
inhibitor which basically inhibits
trypsin which is important because
trypsin activates a lot of these damaged
ins into their active forms so if that
can't happen you won't have a bunch of
active protease in the pancreas which is
good because then you know you're
preventing havoc from being wreaked on
your on your on your pancreas which is
pretty awesome pancreatitis and creati
trypsin inhibitor is pretty much the
real MVP here anyway if you have any
concerns at all about pancreatitis this
is not medical advice in any way shape
or form I'm not a medical professional
if you have any questions about that
please go see your doctor this is all
purely approached from an academic
perspective speaking of which I hope
this video was helpful in getting you to
understand how we take a dietary protein
and break it down into amino acids that
can eventually be taken up into the
blood to the liver hope that video is
helpful thanks for watching if you found
that video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and
happy studying